les à paroles l'état madame
marie-christine dalloz oui merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
le prélèvement à la source grandes
promesses du candidat hollande en 2012
devient aujourd'hui une hypothèse de
réformes
ainsi le gouvernement confirme son
intention de rendre le prélèvement à la
source
effectif au 1er janvier 2018 mais cette
réforme est floue elle est mal préparée
elle laisse trop de questions sans
réponse encore une grande illusion
encore un effet d'annonce monsieur le
premier ministre la commiss la
communication a ses limites
sur la forme une fille qu une
effectivité du prélèvement au 1er
janvier 2018
pourquoi 2018 après vous le déluge
vous prenez une décision qui engagera
l'avenir sans vous encore une illusion
sur le fond vous parlez d'une réforme
irréversible qui doit s'accompagner d'un
cadeau fiscal pour les revenus salariaux
de 2010 cette belle illusion mais de
sérieuses désillusion pour ceux qui
seraient tentés de croire à vos
promesses
faut-il voir un coup politique à cette
annonce
de plus 2017 sera une année blanche au
niveau comptable c'est parfaitement
illusoire
compte tenu du contexte financier actuel
la france est le pays d'europe qui
détient le déficit le plus important la
dette augmente la situation est très
critique vous avancer l'argument du
lissage autres grandes illusions si une
dépense peut se glisser sur plusieurs
années expliquez-moi par quel tour de
magie voulu c'est une recette sur
plusieurs années enfin l'an pauvre
l'impôt français est familiarisé quel
sera l'impact de cette mesure sur les
familles seront elles encore une fois
les plus impactés par votre matraquage
fiscal le gouvernement ayrault avait
annoncé que neuf français sur dix ne
seraient pas touchés par les hausses
d'impôts quelle désillusion cette
réforme monsieur le premier ministre
n'est-elle qu'un miroir aux alouettes
pour appâter les français messieurs
christian eckert secrétaire d'état
chargé du budget
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés madame la députée
marie-christine dalloz ouvrait d'abord
vous préciser un certain nombre de
points que pour vous rassurer
premièrement c'est que les grands
principes de l'impôt sur le revenu ne
seront pas changés
il restera familialiser le quotient
familial subsistera la notion de foyer
fiscal comme sa progressivité seront
maintenus l'objectif est de rapprocher
le moment où l'on paie l'impôt sur le
revenu du moment où l'on perçoit le
revenu pourquoi parce que certains qui
voient leurs revenus baisser sont encore
soumis à l'impôt de l'année précédente
et se voient dans des difficultés alors
concrètement la députée
que va-t-il se passer en 2010 est
l'impôt sur le revenu sera payée calculé
sur la base des revenus perçus en 2016
comme d'habitude en 2018
l'impôt sur le revenu qui sera payé sera
payé sur la base des revenus de l'année
donc concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut
dire les contribuables seront soumis
tous les ans à une annuité d'impôt sur
le revenu
padane est double quant au budget de
l'état il sera alimenté tous les ans par
le produit de cet impôt annuel sur les
revenus issus glisse eu des difficultés
je veux bien le reconnaître lesseps à ce
travail que le gouvernement vous invite
avec les parlementaires avec l'ensemble
des acteurs sensible à ces questions et
donc madame la députée je vous répète
que beaucoup d'entre vous l'ont souhaité
un certain nombre d'intervenants y
compris sur vos rangs l'eau souhaité
avec toutes les questions qui nous faut
encore résoudre
nous mettrons en oeuvre sereinement et
sans précipitation
la retenue à la sner si la morale et
demi